joining me now candice owens host of the
candace owen show and founder of blexit
candace
abram strikes me uh as not only
destructive as a politician but
she she feels entitled
to the governorship your reaction
yeah she does feel entitled i think that
she's one of those people that you can
say is is true to her soul a black lives
matter activist and i don't mean that in
a good way i'm talking about you know
illogically always throwing race into
the narrative thinks that she's she
should be the first that people should
listen to everything she says uh simply
because she's a black woman um and she
really does have bad policies and let's
let's not forget she's also impossibly
corrupt you know stacey abrams it was
her sister that was a federal judge who
dismissed when they wanted to clean up
their voter roles in georgia she wants
to make sure that people can get on the
voter rolls that are not eligible to
vote to make sure that she can win
elections so she is somebody that you
should watch out for i can't imagine why
any person any sane individual would
want her leading their state unless you
are a glutton for crime a glutton for
punishment um you're a fan of maybe the
batman movies and you want to see what
it looked like to live in gotham city
but there there's really no no reason
that any sane person would want to turn
georgia into a new york or an l.a
situation but like i said people should
pay attention because she is very
corrupt and she is very connected and
she has shown in the past that she will
do nothing to stop winning to stop
herself from winning yeah the economy in
georgia especially atlanta
is doing amazingly well and you know
brian kemp has
received a lot of criticism regarding
the election how he handled the election
integrity issues
but you can't argue with his decision to
open up that state when
most other states weren't opening he
opened up first that propelled his state
to a great period of growth how does she
answer that
she doesn't you know her answer to that
is just look i'm a black woman atlanta's
a black city and you're going to thrive
under me it's the same lie and
unfortunately in too many circumstances
it works amongst black democratic voters
i think that's because somebody looks
like them um that person is going to get
into often is going to further um the
things that they need to get done and
that's just not true the evidence as you
said is shown by the city of atlanta it
has thrived under uh republican
leadership and that's because it doesn't
matter what your race is in this country
the policies that work are the policies
and and the um ideas that this country
was founded upon free market policies
opening the economy you know not forcing
businesses to shut down because uh you
have fears about a virus allowing people
to make the decisions by themselves as
individuals allowing free market
competition um and she stands for the
exact opposite uh she believes that
people should be placed in society in a
pecking order according to their race
you know if you are black and you are a
woman you should be ahead of someone
because you're white it is not the right
way to look at an economy it's not the
right way to look at georgia as a state
and unfortunately people don't wake up
to that and understand that um they are
at very big risk right now of of losing
everything that georgia has had all the
success that has seen under a governor
brian kemp now look at what has happened
to biden he chose kamala harris
for diversity
reasons that's the only reason he chose
her she's obviously flatlining she's not
popular she has staff quitting one after
the other the press corps knows she's in
big trouble
the same thing is going to happen
in georgia you know abrams has you know
bigger personality for sure and maybe a
lot more celebrity friends but
there's a parallel somewhat here is
there not between the two
there definitely is the only thing i
will say is that you do have to give her
credit april's has much more personality
than kamala i mean this is a woman that
is makes hillary clinton look like she's
likable you know kamala harris was it
was an absolute mistake to pick her um
and but yes in terms of wanting to
entirely make the conversation in this
country about race to not actually focus
on policies that work and to think that
just by showing up and being black for
kamala being half black that that should
be enough and you should have to do
nothing else i think that is a very
direct parallel to the same ideas that's
what they want to see this country
become and it's not something that
republicans believe in you know we
believe in a meritocracy has nothing to
do with race
stacey abrams candace it looks like she
thinks that one way
to encourage growth in her state is
through the growth industry of abortion
watch
under this governor we have seen a
retrenchment on voter suppression and
that is action we need to take and i'm
deeply concerned about the
anti-choice law that governor kemp
signed in 2019 that drove away jobs and
is hurting the state of georgia
candace is she kidding me it's
abortion is going to revitalize an
economy that's already strong
it's disgusting for a lot of reasons
when you see black american especially
black american women getting on a
platform and being so vocally in support
of abortion knowing that this is an
industry uh planned parenthood you know
this was literally founded by
eugenicists who believe that black
americans shouldn't be allowed to
procreate
what it's demonstrating is just a
tremendous ignorance and when you see
black americans saying yes more abortion
it's like watching turkeys vote for
thanksgiving we know that the black
population would be double what it is
today had it not been for abortion if it
hadn't been for the targeted clinics
that are in the black and hispanic
communities the black community the
black population would be double um so
it's despicable but you know what she's
a part of a party and she's a part of a
democratic machine they do not care to
her black americans are simply votes and
the best way to get those votes is to
emotionally engineer those people to
talk about racism ad nauseam and to hope
they never actually look at the policies
that are being presented well crime and
decline they don't want that in georgia
they want growth and prosperity and
candace it's great to see you back on
the show thanks so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else